foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where dead is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice well we're here to help
you
win with your money but also win in
other areas of your life and oddly
enough when you win with your money it
helps the rest of Life seem to go a
little bit smoother we're going to talk
about money we're going to talk about
relationships we'll talk about your work
getting that bigger shovel to be able to
get out of debt or build the wealth that
you desire to build and we're going to
have fun doing it I'm Ken Coleman joined
by my colleague Ramsey personality multi
best selling author Rachel Cruz and
she's also just really fun and so we're
gonna have a good time today take the
pressure off somebody may need some
breakthrough today and you're a free
phone call away triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five so
before we get to the phones you and
George Campbell our colleague launched a
new podcast speaking of fun we did but
but not just fun for the sake of fun
sort of
well I mean but you're helping people
but it's yeah so talk about it I don't
want to it's it's a smart money happy
hour did I get yeah smart money happy
hour I got nervous I got on the end of
the diving don't worry I didn't have any
notes this is all me talking right now
no I love it you're loving it thank you
it's a lot of fun yes the podcast is
great yeah so you know we kind of
dreamed this up about a year ago because
we're like we just we want a a place
where kind of selfishly we're like we
just want to record these conversations
that I feel like we have all the time uh
even back with in the personalities Eric
and with you and deloney it's like sure
we have these great conversations and
I'm like man we get to like these really
great conclusions but they're it's it's
real life conversation so I was like I
wanna we wanna bring that and then a pop
culture element and a current events
element things that are happening right
now today okay so I have to ask yeah
because this thing's fresh it's blowing
up go get it wherever you listen to
podcasts go check it out because you
cover current events yes will there be
a little coverage of the midterm
elections coming
hard news but are you going to cover it
like hey you know we've kind of said
which hurts my heart you're not going to
touch it we may not touch politics okay
so you and I should start a podcast well
no that's a whole separate one so we're
no I know I know that's what I'm saying
my way completely I
conspiracy theory podcast I would have a
midterm election podcast
have a reality show podcast I could do a
lot that's all I'll say I could cover a
lot of bases that only probably a
fraction of the population actually
cares Rachel is a great
conversationalist I'm just going to tell
you that it doesn't matter what the
topic is she's going to make it fun so
let's do it Lauren is up first as we get
going in this hour in Dallas Texas
Lauren how can we help
hi Ken hi Rachel love uh love your show
excited to talk to you so my question is
before I started following Dave Ramsey I
took out a 401k loan now I'm in a
situation where I have an amazing new
job which is really exciting but that
401k loan is due so do I pay off the
loan or do I take the penalties which is
lower and use the rest of that money to
use towards my debt snowball
okay so how much do you owe on your 401k
there's nine thousand dollars left oh
okay and how much how much cash do you
have
um probably about three thousand three
thousand okay but that's just you know
to kind of get us through monthly bills
and stuff yeah sure sure so you you guys
have no other savings at that point
no we're in uh baby step two
okay but we have a big shovel so so how
how much you guys make
um annually we met about 215 000. okay
yeah fantastic for sure
so honestly you guys could have the
money here in like two months if you
just really cut things back and threw it
at this loan
yeah I'm thinking probably three only
because uh the spouse isn't quite as on
board as I am okay why is that
um oh I don't know it's hard to explain
he um he's of the opinion that we make
enough money to be able to enjoy
ourselves
well he's right but that has nothing to
do with paying off debt is he is he on
board with the debt payment
paying off all the debts getting yeah
getting there how much debt do you guys
have total Lauren
90 000. okay and what does that make up
besides the 401K loan
40 000 in a car 24 000 in student loans
14 000 in a line of credit
nine thousand four one K and then the
rest just some little miscellaneous
stuff yeah
um okay well if I were you I would I
would scrape the money together yeah and
as fast as possible but I am going to
encourage you learn that you know
you can do this and and and it works and
you will be you know out of that loan
and everything but but the anchor that's
going to be dragging
it it is your husband like it's it's
your spouse and I know you didn't call
for that specifically but a lot of even
the numbers you just gave me I'm like
man if you guys were on the same team
and on board uh together how how much
faster you'd be able to attack all of
this debt so for him
um he just feels like y'all can just
y'all should just have fun and you make
good money so it's like let's just enjoy
it what's your motivation to to get out
of debt and pay it off
um I just kind of leaving a legacy and
building generational wealth that can
really bless and help a lot of people
and set us up for a retirement where um
I think security is the main thing for
me I just don't have to worry about
anything yeah for sure which is a
women's Number One Financial Fear Can is
the lack of security
um so yeah Lauren I mean I know you
didn't call about for the marriage
question but but I but I would I would I
would communicate that because under a
lot of this motivation to become debt
free yes there is the aspirational you
know for my kids to leave a legacy and
all of that is very true and very good
but usually that first motivation it's
coming from either a place of fear like
what you're saying a place of
um you know that insecurity that if
something happens are we going to be
okay you want the security aspect of the
money
um which is having three thousand
dollars you guys make incredible money
do you know what I'm saying so like
um this that this could be a different
way but communicating that deeper uh
motivation for you to your husband I
think would be a I would encourage you
to have that conversation because I
think that's going to play out in other
areas of your marriage not just the
money routes
um but to answer your question yeah pay
it off uh and get it done in in two
months but I think I know you said three
I'm gonna push you to two yeah but I
would uh encourage the work on the
marriage piece of this because I think
that there's there's really great depth
that can occur in marriage uh when you
both decide hey we're going to engage
this topic and it's probably
uncomfortable for you Lauren to be like
I don't want to bring it up because I
know he doesn't want to do it you don't
want to feel like you're a pain he
doesn't want to hear it maybe so so
there's that that tension but that's the
exact tension that I'm like that you
want to dive into you know yeah but I
would also add Vision to it I think you
have to address hey this is how I'm
feeling and he has to live with the
tension but you also want to try to cast
Vision because he's just looking at us
wait we make too much money I want to
have some fun and do all this and that's
that's the surface issue he needs to
understand your safety gland is is going
off five alarm fire also a vision for
the future that you talked about with
Rachel hey for a little bit of sacrifice
buckling down for just a little bit of
time in the grand scheme of our life we
can reach this Vision here you know
sometimes spouses need to see a vision
not just all the sacrifice I would try
it that way as well great advice Rachel
Lauren thanks for the call don't move
more Ramsey show coming right up
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show
we're talking about your life
specifically your money your work your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman Rachel
Cruz joins me this hour we're here for
you the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to Jefferson
City Missouri where Linda awaits Linda
how can we help
hi um thank you so much for taking my
call I'm calling because my family and I
are in babysit too
um we're brand new to trying the Ramsay
program
um my husband has been the budgeter
wanting to budget for the last 22 years
and I am embarrassed to say that I was
kind of kicking and screaming along the
way and just this July I found your
podcast I read the baby stuff the the
Money Makeover and I'm completely on
board and I want to get our financial
heads together we
um of course when we get in line we are
hit with a significant tragedy and our
daughter
um was very ill and we needed to put her
into a residential facility
um to help yeah it's it's it's very sad
um but so she was released to the
partial hospitalization program
yesterday and she'll be there for about
a month and so my question is is when we
had to make this decision to get the
support she needed
um we we depleted our Healthcare savings
account
um to cover the in-network deductible to
pay for her so when she comes out in
four weeks we have to seek a
nutritionist and a therapist to support
her so she can we can protect the
progress she's making
the best people in our area are out of
network which I prayed to get connected
with them and we did but they're out of
network so it's going to cost our
families sixteen hundred dollars a month
just for her to see these the support
people we will be replenishing our
health care savings account but we won't
be replenishing it as quick as the bills
will be due to for the support and so my
question is how do I use the every
dollar budget how do I use the Ramsay
plan to account for the money going out
to pay for the support knowing that we
will be repaying ourselves sometime down
the road and the insurance will also
repay us I think 60 out of network
my brain fried with all of how do I
account for this in the budget like I
said my husband I basically wore him
down over the years and now that I'm
interested in budgeting he is having a
hard time getting on board with wanting
to do it yeah well I was going to say
the the 20-year answer to prayer for you
to come on board Linda now you're
hearing your husband yeah uh has that
well let me say this you know when it
comes to our kids like we do anything
right like there's money at that point
is not even a factor like we are we're
going to help our kids in any situation
and so um you guys are fantastic parents
uh for doing that so the 1600 a month
how much do you guys bring home a month
and um
my husband has an awesome job and we're
right at um around 10 10 000 a month
okay okay that's great
um I have a quick question uh just a
technical question Linda uh you're
saying that insurance won't pick up the
60 right away it'll be a while is that
what I understood
okay that is correct we get a super Bill
my understanding is we'll get a super
bill at the end of the month that will
account for the visits we had that month
and then we submit that to insurance and
there's a little bit of a lag time but
we should get 60 of that refunded to go
towards our out of network deductibles
okay okay
uh and how how long do you think this um
these two specific treatments for the
nutritionist
um and uh the other one I'm sorry
um is it a physical therapist
um um a therapist a therapist therapist
how long do you do you has anyone given
you a timeline on those expenses like
will this be for the next five years
will this be for the next five months do
you know how how um ongoing this will be
um I'm guessing well they told us
roughly a year okay but likely we'll
have some sort of support okay for the
foreseeable future just to keep her in a
healthy place and you're right we would
sell our house we would do anything for
her to get better yeah absolutely
absolutely and I'm thankful she is it
sounds like she's progressing well which
which is um a praise for sure so if I
were you Linda um I would look at the
next year and just say hey we have a
1600 expense every month and I would
just put it in the ever dollar budget
and that means you're gonna have to
limit probably you have to lower some
other categories in order to get that
margin of that 1600 and I would put that
as a necessity you know we talk about
the four walls food shelter utilities
transportation and this is right under
that for me I'm like it's you know you
it's right in that necessity uh bucket
before other things before shopping for
clothes before entertainment right
before out to eat this is a necessity
for your family for the next 12 months
um from what you've expected so so I
would put that and then any money that
you get from insurance ongoing I would
just say hey is an extra bump to even
throw at the debt snowball you said you
guys are working your way out of debt so
you could even use that extra 60 that
you're going to be getting uh you know
which is you know 9 000 bucks or
whatever it may be to throw at uh I'm
sorry 900 to throw at the debt snowball
even so I would just put this as a line
item does that stretch your budget too
much do you feel like
no I I that I can that helps me because
I just wasn't sure where to because
there's so many and like this is coming
in and this is going out and then this
is being refunded that my mind was
spinning and I want to share my husband
with a very clear this is I would just I
would just saying yep I would just say
it's an expense and that that this is
going to be in any extra from the
insurance that comes in uh will be a
bonus to throw at at your debtstop I
think that's right you know we have some
experience Stacy and we had a lot of
healthcare stuff with our kids and and
payments and then all this kind of stuff
you go what's insurance covering Stacy's
really great at this so if she were
sitting here right now so I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know kind of tell you what she
would say uh get on the phone with the
insurance if you have already done it
get on back on the phone with them get
on phone get on phone with the office
manager whoever's in charge of the
billing at the executive I mean excuse
me at the uh at the two different
therapy options and and just say hey
here's where we are insurance is going
to cover 60 from the time you file the
bill or you send us the bill to here can
we work something out
uh most of the time in those situations
they know they're going to get paid they
know your situation so don't be afraid
to at least have a conversation to go
could we work it out this way for the
first month or two until we figure out
what the cycle looks like but to
Rachel's point the safe place to just go
all right we're going to write 1600 line
item in the budget and then after two or
three months of figuring out what the
insurance billing looks like because
you're still looking at about 900 bucks
and some change with with insurance
paying 60 percent they're going to pay
900 of it if that's what it ends up
being so I think that's the safe play
and then that way you're not worried
about the budget overheating yep for
sure and Linda I know you're you're so
motivated I can hear that in your voice
of like you're like I want a budget I
want to get stuff in in control we're on
baby step two all of that and so this
getting out of debt
um part of your journey is something
that obviously we we love we celebrate
being debt free here on the show but we
also say when Big Life stuff happens
there is a time to pause the debt
snowball that's if you're expecting a
child if you know there's gonna be a big
move coming up uh you know there are
times for a short period of time to
pause so I know that you are so
motivated but just of how close to home
and how quickly and things are changing
with her health
if you wanted to pause uh for 30 60 days
from the dead snowball pile up some
money and kind of get this new Norm
under you
um and then throw it at the debt but I
do want to give you a little bit of
breathing room as a mom because
um there's a lot if you try to do too
much I feel like it can be overwhelming
and it can almost be that defeating so I
love how I love how excited you are and
I would still have those numbers of
destinable in front of you I would still
have that factor of motivation but if
you need like a 30-day you know
Breathing Room give yourself some Grace
in that too okay yeah absolutely no that
sounds important it's hard to not as a
mom just not to keep your head down and
keep barreling forward yeah you know for
sure and I know if Dr John deloney was
sitting here too I think that you know
walking through that um yeah that part
of the work for you as a mom too is
really important taking care of yourself
and I the term self-care felt gets
thrown out so often but truly you know
uh the pain associated possibly with
what happened with your daughter I mean
all of that right there's so much for us
as people so many layers and taking care
of all of that uh is so important but
I'm proud of you guys absolutely and I
think Rachel's right your head needs to
be down for your daughter right now
let's get that stabilized and that
burden hopefully off of your shoulders
uh and you'll be able to pay the debt
off I'm not worried about that at all
thank you so much for sharing your story
with us we just believe better things
are ahead hoping the best for your
family it's a tough tough storm but you
will walk through it all right folks
don't move more of your questions coming
up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman joined by Rachel Cruz we're
thrilled that you were with us this hour
it is a free phone call if you want to
jump in triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
Craig in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Craig
how can we help
hey there guys thanks for taking my call
I appreciate it you bet for you guys do
on a daily basis you guys are helping a
lot of people so
um so my question is proud to
um my wife or I have for the plan a few
years ago we're now in uh baby steps
four five and six
um and part of that is one of our
daughters a freshman in college so we're
helping cash flow that
um but our question is we're trying to
dump extra money into the house we have
three vehicles that are a little bit
older because we didn't want to upgrade
while we're paying off that so my wife
is thinking maybe we should start
putting some money into a fund aside to
save for cars or as I want to just keep
tackling the house and I guess the
question is is like how did you figure
out at this point which is you know and
that is not a right answer but what
direction to go well I'm going to jump
in first because this is non-financial
advice so I'll let my my co-host the
financial expert weigh in but I'm going
to weigh in as a dude who's been married
24 and a half years
you got the money you have the income
and the discipline
when Mama says that she wants to uh open
up a fund to replace her car you need to
go okay sweetheart we're gonna start
that I'll have a new budget to you in
the morning if you if you want to Craig
keep driving an older car and just pile
money in the house that's that's your
call well I think I'd start funding a
new car for your wife that's the uh see
I told you it wasn't Financial advice
now you got to make that work Rachel
fantastic Financial advice it's
relational first pal that's what I'm
looking out for you right now well I was
gonna say Craig I mean you don't have to
replace all three cars at the exact same
time so find the one that's that's
either just needed
I was gonna give an A or B option
there's no option that is needed
or her car
and just do you have you guys run any
numbers since she's the one that asks
obviously I know we're kind of joking
with her but does she know what she
wants like do you guys have you run any
numbers of like the type of cars she
wants or anything just it's more just an
idea I mean we just no I mean it's for a
specific cars though we talked about
pricing like we we're kind of thinking
if we could probably get something
decent for around 15 000 so that's kind
of what we're planning to do but we do
have a car that's a little bit older
more of a beater car that my daughter
has in school and the last inspection
there was concerns over the frame uh
maybe not passing that inspection uh hey
can you move your Craig can you move
your phone a little bit we're kind of
coming into now sorry all right let's
keep going yeah so the third car is the
daughter's beater that she's using at
college
hey College in our last inspection they
had mentioned that the frame is starting
to rot and they didn't think it would
pass the next inspection so the real
reason so now we're trying to look in
her car we're on my wife's car runs but
it's not perfect he he can't reverse on
pills because if it's like transmission
problems
buddy this is your intervention
your wife's in a car that won't go in
reverse man only uphill Craig is saying
I thank you I think you need a buyer a
car I think
you guys are killing me no
so no for real though on a tactical
level Craig I would say okay yeah 15 000
for your wife's car daughter with the
bad frame beater she can hold off first
she can get six eight months she can
bike around College these kids man these
kids what do they expect get a bicycle
oh my gosh Craig I'm here for you okay
so so yeah I would say Okay 15 000 if
that's what it is figure out how much
you can sell hers for Kelly Blue Book it
figure out the difference and then you
create a sinking fund and then every
month still putting a little bit of
extra towards the house but slow the
house down then say okay how many months
do we have to save up to get that
whatever the difference is let's say
it's eight grand I don't know what it
would be well it can't reverse so you're
probably you may not get a lot of money
for her car I don't know uh but just to
say okay figure out the math have a game
plan have a sinking fund which means in
the budget for from this month on Craig
October through however long it's going
to take you guys to say put some money
aside for her car
and then we can you can check out the
daughter's car after that um but that's
what I would do but you're still putting
extra towards the house you're gonna
just slow it down he wants to go
full-fledged I love that uh but I would
pull back on the house some still add
some extra money towards the mortgage so
you're still putting extra towards the
house but pull back a little bit to save
up and get your wife a car if he doesn't
get her a car he's going to be sleeping
outside of this house he wants to pay
off so badly I'm just telling you I'm
just here for you Craig you're a good
guy you're crushing it I love the
gazelle intensity your wife's gonna love
us oh I know she's gonna hear this calm
thing hi somebody should send her the
link to that I'm going to be her
favorite host ever I'm like come on man
all right good stuff hey Craig you're
awesome uh you guys are gonna get there
uh you really are and you've been
disciplined at this point good on you
but now is time I mean when the car
won't go in gear it's probably a sign
that it's time to begin to replace it uh
let's go to Ben in Medford Oregon Ben
how can we help
hey guys how you doing today good
good hey so my wife and I
um recently had a baby about seven weeks
ago that's awesome you sound you sound
sharp you could sleep I was in a fog
about your stage right now my my wife is
pretty good about letting me get sleep
and I'm like you need to let me she's
one of those wives
[Laughter]
yeah so we've got about we've got about
twelve hundred dollars um in medical
debt from that and then my nine-year-old
son needs braces and that's going to be
about another sixteen hundred bucks uh
we have a fully funded emergency fund
and so I'm kind of wondering do we take
it out of the emergency fund and then
pause our investments and then until we
build our emergency fund back up or do
we just pause our investments try to
cash flow it the the baby bit is kind of
like it's due at the end of the month
the dental debt is kind of like they
need 120 now to do the down payment and
then they said we can pay it off over
the next year no interest but I'm kind
of like I don't want to have anything
that even sounds remotely like that even
if there's no interest or whatever so
I'm just kind of curious what you guys
recommend for trying to pay that off
quickly either emergency fund or try to
cash flow it or yeah
um how much is in the emergency fund
uh 12 Grand 12 Grand okay and how much
you guys make a year
um we make about 140 before taxes 140
before taxes okay and so monthly
take-home pay
um um
like nine-ish okay
I mean if I were you better I mean it's
2800 bucks
we had a call like this last weekend I I
would push just the cash flow it so that
you keep on
uh investing you don't have to pause
that go through the hassle of that
you're not dipping into the emergency
fund and I would just say hey for the
next month like we're really just gonna
pull back and uh get I mean if you have
to dip into it a little bit then you
know that's what it's there for uh but
these aren't you know when it comes to
an emergency fund really one of the big
filters is is it unexpected so the baby
wasn't unexpected right nine months
correct uh and then braces I don't know
how you know if it he went to the
dentist like he needs them now or
whatever it is
um but that's kind of a filter that I
use uh to really dip into the emergency
fund and feel good about it but if you
guys can cash flow it bin I would just
so you don't have to like go back a step
right if you have the cash and you're
and you guys can just push through it
this month that's what I would encourage
you to do or next month like if you just
need a little bit for the braces now but
you can pay it pay the rest off I'd pay
the hospital for the baby if you don't
have enough to pay the braces in full I
do a down payment on the braces then pay
it all off yeah you're not accruing
interest on that it's not like a
traditional debt you're going to crush
that that way you don't dip in your
emergency fund and you keep on moving
yeah boy I'll tell you what kids and
braces you're not there yet we're not
there yet I never had braces Ken oh
lovely teeth thank you wow I think Dave
and Sharon for that they owe me some
money saved their money is what happens
oh I'd like to be a part of that
conversation I'd like you to pull that
number together amortize it with a
little bit of interest and let's present
that to date hey don't move more Ramsey
show coming up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life your money
your relationships your work here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined by
Rachel Cruz we are here for you this
hour it's a free phone call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five paying
off debt is always smart saving and
investing is smart but there's one key
to winning with money that most people
Overlook and that's protecting your
finances from emergencies this is why
insurance is so vitally important there
are 10 kinds of insurance coverage you
might need based on what life looks like
for you today we've built a tool called
the coverage checkup it's a fabulous
little tool I've used it and it's going
to show you what types of insurance you
may need to add or drop or adjust or
even going to rank your coverage list by
importance email it to you and then
connect you with Ramsey trusted
insurance providers so that you can take
care of what you need to do this could
be the most important five minutes you
spend today we recently had one of our
uh viewers and listeners do this and
Donald H wrote in for anyone who has not
completed this checkup do it now you
never know when something will happen
and you never want to leave your family
in a bad situation I think Donald H is
sleeping better at night and you could
too go to ramseysolutions.com checkup
that's
ramseysolutions.com
checkup Minneapolis Minnesota is where
David awaits David how can we help
hey Ken and Rachel thanks for taking my
call so calling for kind of how to have
a financial conversation with your
significant other
um so my girlfriend and I have been
seeing each other since the beginning of
the year I've been dating most of that
time and I understand that finances are
one of those big ticket items uh that we
definitely need to be on the same page
before I put a ring on it hahaha
um we had one a few months ago and we
shared a few a few things uh
specifically our our overall debt number
and I could tell that she was very
uneasy and uncomfortable and probably
felt some shame and uh so we were
dealing with a lot of other things so
I'm like hey let's put put this
conversation on the shelf and we'll
address it later uh and we've been fine
since then with uh regarding that and I
just would like to hear your thoughts on
how to have that conversation uh how to
enter in that conversation how to have
boundaries uh do we need a third party
uh to help uh mediate that conversation
how serious is this gal for you
uh pretty darn
are you guys even talking about marriage
so uh not yet
um but that's because she is like we
have agreed not to do any like
progression forward uh because she is in
her first year of uh residency and
that's a very taxing year and I'm on the
uh I'm on the uh the the uh idea of uh
engagement should be three to six months
and we're not even near that um all
right like that time frame that time
scheduling frame I I don't know what
Rachel's gonna say but that's what makes
this show fun uh I I think that I would
be talking to to her about
uh General uh thoughts about money like
what do you think about debt last time
you kind of talked about here's how much
debt I have and then she told you how
much she had you felt like she was
shameful about it and all that kind of
stuff but that's not talking about
philosophies and this is really about
philosophical thoughts about money which
is something what do you believe about
money what do you value what do you care
about
um I don't want to have debt I would
like to pay off all my debt once I pay
it off in my marriage I don't want us to
do that I mean you don't have to talk
about marriage per se but just talking
about your views and thoughts about
money and I'd start there hey I'm just
curious what do you think about this
this is what I think about money this is
what I believe about money
does that hit you the wrong way what do
you think I'd make it all about you so
you don't put her on the defensive and
then you're gonna lay out your values on
money and I would see how she reacts to
that is she just asking legitimate
inquisitive type you know I mean just
I'm just getting to the bottom of what
you believe uh or does she have some
sort of problem with it but Rachel I
kind of stay there it seems to where
they're at in their relationship I
wouldn't go much deeper than just
putting your values out and seeing how
she reacts to it yeah because regardless
of her number of how much that she has
with if she's in residency and she took
out medical bills supposedly or medical
debt or sorry medical student loans yes
to go to medical school there's probably
going to be a lot but regardless of the
number that's not a reason not to marry
someone but a different value systems
that's your red flag and that's what Ken
is saying and I think that that's what's
wise is to have these overall but you
guys how old are you guys
uh so I'm uh 34 and she's
um uh 39 or 29. okay so y'all are I mean
at the age you're not like 18 and 19
where it's like the word marriage could
scare us if you guys are at the point
and as adults that you know if you're
dating for a significant period of time
for them well I guess in my head it's
eventually going to go somewhere so what
do you think about this is what I wanted
to know because the female opinion
versus the male opinion do you do you
sense anything where she said oh let's
just not Advance the relationship until
I get through year one I had a little
red flag but that's coming from a dude's
perspective that's why I'm putting that
out there do you see a red flag I I know
that it is a taxing it is not a question
but I think that there's a lot of things
in life that are very taxing and I would
want to do it with Winston as my husband
okay uh so I would like him to have this
conversation I know I want your opinion
on this I'd like him to have this
conversation about money sooner rather
than later yeah and I would say it's one
of those conversations along with other
conversations of values so yeah yeah
having the values conversation on money
hey you know when I what I see in my
life in the next three years is being
married and when it comes to money I
want to be able to have you know no debt
pay it off if
um my future spouse who's you're my
long-term girlfriend so that's probably
gonna be you like yeah paying off debt
living debt free being intentional to
our money having goals uh all of that is
a value of yours David and then you know
kids there's another big conversation on
kids uh in-laws sex I mean like oh like
these are Big life conversations that
you have to have before marriage and
money yes is one of them and at the top
of the list like you said David because
it does cause a lot of tension so making
sure that you guys have the same values
but also David can I just can I say this
I don't know you oh I'm very excited but
I I kind of think you just need to kind
of just relax a little bit oh I do too
much
it's a three to six month window of
Engagement I was like yeah why what what
what what in Crazy World David would you
just say let's go to the courthouse
we've been dating him month I remember
we were just dating a year and let's
just go right I do think you've got
things in a box and I can tell you that
life rarely fits neatly into the box I
could not hurt your feelings David what
do you think
so the the the the the uh the window of
Engagement is that's how long I think
engagement should be
um three months if if you if uh
three months I think is on the shorter
end of Engagement six months is longer
asterisks you know circumstances seven
months so I know I talked to her about
that while we're at it I'd add that one
to the left yeah yeah
um and so and I'm fine waiting but
um like I'm fine waiting what's another
six months or so
um and I know that she doesn't have a
whole lot of bandwidth because of
residency is very very taxing yeah I
want to plan a wedding and all of that
so I get that yes 100 and I want I want
to like
um take as many things off her place and
not necessarily put me more things on
her plate like these more
um in-depth conversations but no no no
that's a cop-out I'm gonna tell you that
right now that is not putting more on
our plate you need to figure out you're
very serious about this and I get it I
love a man with a plan I love a man with
an opinion but you need to find out if
you guys are on the same page
um and I sooner rather than later she's
not too busy that she can't have the
conversation that Rachel said yes yeah
and because these conversations too
David they bring a level of depth to
your relationship you get to you know
her on a deeper level and so that's not
adding more to her plate that's actually
like loving her really well and wanting
to know more of who she is and that so
like to me that's a real that's a
relationship that's not
um yeah that's not adding more to her
plate that's that's being a significant
other in my opinion I got a bad feeling
oh no kid I really do this is not a
relationship show uh but I'd love to
have one uh because if it was I would
say my friend friend we need to have
this conversation and everything else
pretty darn soon feels like you may be
getting the Heisman Trophy stance coming
at you a little bit and she's blaming
the cut the school and the it's a lot
okay or David's gone on really tough and
he's like tell me how much debt you have
and she's like you're making my pie
thank you yeah he could be a little too
intense maybe she needs to breathe a
little bit right so if you're three to
six month engagement rule so maybe too
much for her I don't know it's
interesting stuff have the conversation
sooner rather than later all of them
David embrace it
great hour Rachel Cruz so much fun
thanks to the team uh in the control
room for keeping us on the air to you
America thank you for listening this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
this is the Ramsey show where we talk
about your life specifically your money
your work your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
we are here for you it is a free phone
call Triple eight eight two five five
two two five that is triple eight eight
two five five two two five gonna have
some fun today these may be some tough
topics but uh we're gonna just meet you
where you are and hopefully give you
some very clear steps to take so that
you can see some transformation in the
area of your life where you need it
we're going to go to Midland Texas now
where Douglas joins us Douglas how can
we help
how are you guys doing today we're
having a blast Douglas what's up
well um my wife and I started a oil
field services company uh four years ago
February 2019 and it's gone in a
direction that we haven't really
anticipating we're hoping but it's now
we're here and we've got uh great
Revenue but at the end of the month
every month we look and it's like
there's not enough money in the bank
what what are we doing wrong and this is
kind of where we thought you know what
it's time to look up to the
professionals and uh you know see where
we need to make some corrections and get
this back on track so we can try to keep
some of our million dollars a year in
the bank instead of letting it go yeah I
was curious what is your what are your
gross revenues
uh we're we're doing uh this year will
be just right out a million dollars if
not just a hair over we got the
thermometer on the wall to kind of keep
the kids excited to see if you plan
ahead and set goals that you can reach
them okay and uh how many employees
uh just my wife and I and we hire
subcontractors if we need extra
equipment so we hire people with trucks
if we need help who does your
bookkeeping
my wife does we use sage in the office
yeah
um yes yes it's overwhelming for her at
times okay well that means she's not
good at it that's not a bad thing it
means it may not be her skill set it may
be too intense and here's where I'm
going with that I I do think on on a
just a basic level you should probably
think about getting a really good
accountant who is experiencing these
things and maybe take off some of some
of that off of her plate if she's
overwhelmed the other thing is is if you
guys aren't in the numbers deep enough
to know why there's no money left over
then you know getting maybe an outside
set of eyes to go hey your operating
expenses are out of control here here or
here I just think that's a starting
Place does that make sense
it does yeah we do have a CPA that does
our tax returns for us yeah that's
different but your taxes are different
here's my question do you feel like you
know right now
why you guys aren't keeping enough money
no so you don't know does your wife know
if you were on the phone could she say
yeah Ken it's this area this area in
this area and our operating expenses and
it's the cost of doing business it's
really high here and so we've had to
invest would she be able to articulate
why there's no money left over in this
nearly Million Dollar business
no that's my point
yeah okay I get it now I mean I'm not
being unkind I mean I'm saying like it's
not a skill set like I couldn't do it
for you guys you wouldn't want me doing
that work a true understanding of the
numbers in the organization we got to
know where the money is and where it's
going to then be able to go all right
now we can do a budget but you can't do
a budget if you don't know what the
numbers are and where they are so I mean
we first need to get a handle of that
exactly like I have a hair brain budget
and it's like this is what it costs to
operate 36 000 a month so I look at that
as what I need to do for Revenue minimum
and then after that we can start you
know can we save here can we save there
because my big thing is is I'm 55 my
wife is 57 and
um you know I'm looking telling her we
need to start putting away for
retirement this is what we've got more
than we anticipated what can we say
suppose well there's not enough money to
put away and I'm like well hold on a
second all right hold on a second yeah
so um you've got in your idea thirty six
thousand dollars a month that's in your
head of what we would need to cover give
me an idea we're in October right now
what's been your highest grossing month
this year
uh 117 000. okay
my man that's your highest grossing
month what's your lowest grossing month
forty six thousand so in your lowest
grossing month
you out did your 36 000 hair brain we
don't know if that's right but that's in
your head but that's what this is as
simple as it gets we've got to look at
the numbers and go what are our hard
costs like and then once we see our hard
costs do we have debt does the company
have debt
uh very minimal we have one piece of
equipment that those Wheels 17 000 on it
everything else is so far what are you
so what is your business give me the 30
second description of your business
we have uh uh which trucks in the oil
field
um and a hot shot service we work
primarily production on purpose okay
Drilling in the other areas to the oil
filter two it fluctuates too much all
prices drop drilling spots where are
your expenses I know you don't know the
details we've established that but what
do you think your number one expenses
insurance is huge like a medical for my
wife and I in the family is 3 600
liability insurance for the company is 7
500 a month
um and then auto policy on the vehicles
is 4 000 a year
um so basically a hundred dollars or 200
400 a month do money on the trucks on
the vehicles the company vehicles
uh company vehicles uh one the Toyota
pickup we've borrowed money against it
it was paid off we put a thirty thousand
dollar loan against it oh my God and and
so we needed some operating capital in
the beginning and of course that's high
interest and we're that's the first one
I want to get paid off is that one all
right so here's the deal the I've
already given you the advice but I want
to steer you you've got the money to do
this but I want you to take a 30-day
free trial okay of entree leadership
Elite entree leadership is our business
division we help leaders all shape sizes
of companies and we teach you how to run
your business the way we run Ramsey
Solutions
okay it comes from Dave's principles
it's called entree leadership Elite
here's the website
ramseysolutions.com elite
ramseysolutions.com elite I want you to
sign up for the 30-day free trial and I
mean dive in deep get on the phone
you're going to get access to all of our
coaches videos on the stuff you guys
have got to learn how to do a business
budget you've got to get in love with
this phrase called retained earnings
okay which is just savings okay you guys
have got company debt you got to pay
that debt down I don't think income is
your problem I just think you guys bless
your heart husband and wife team you've
really stumbled and not stumbled you
you've intentionally started a business
doing well it's got a huge ceiling is
that fair to say
oh yeah if I this was another question
it's like okay I'm always hearing on the
Ramsay show you know sell your vehicles
pay off the vehicle that vehicle that's
terrible terrible well we make our money
with vehicles and I'm looking at uh
borrowing a hundred grand to put towards
another piece of equipment no
potentially generated no no no you just
need to pay off your debt okay hang on
the line Douglas if you keep doing what
you've been doing you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting and you
guys are in some bad habits within your
business and so really diving into this
Elite Entre leadership Elite and you
guys you got to change course you got to
change what you've been doing you want
to see that million dollars you want to
see it and if you do this just gonna be
going right back out to payments yeah
and this is a simple fix it is awareness
and then discipline okay those two words
are your friends that's what we're gonna
do Andre Elise gonna coach you and get
you started and I'd sign up the minute
that the free trial uh expired because
it can really help you guys are a Texas
tornado and you gotta get control of
what's going on thank you so much for
the call wishing the best for you this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
so thrilled that you have joined us as
we talk about your life your money your
work your relationships she is Rachel
Cruz I am Ken Coleman so happy to be
with you it is a free phone call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
for shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more make sure you use the promo code
Ramsey to get the best deal Rachel
today's question comes from Rebecca in
Arkansas my father recently passed away
and in his will it stated that each
grandchild will receive twenty thousand
dollars but not until their 31st
birthday my kids are 12 8 and 5. what
kind of account should I put their money
in until they can have it at 31. oh
that's a great question how nice and
what a legacy there 20 grand okay so if
I were you Rebecca
um anything that's longer than five
years I love the idea of investing it
because while the market is down now
we have the confidence that it's gonna
go back up like we just believe in the
American economy enough that by the way
they're breaking news to support you
these last two days stock market big
time back over 30 000. so the roller
coaster we talk about it's going up well
in October they're expecting it to all
go down so there you go see you never
know just the last two days we don't
know what tomorrow is but overall oh we
believe in the grow like you look at the
stock market in general and it has grown
has there has there been ups and downs
yeah because that's why it looks like a
roller coaster when you look at the
chart it's up and down up and down but
eventually it's it's going up that's
always the trajectory so uh so yeah I
mean even if it's just like a mutual
fund and put the money in and be able
whether it's opening up three or just
one and putting all in and then under
you know I guess I would do three to
have them all separate and then yep
five-year-olds will probably get the
benefit more get more at the end of the
day because it's going to be in there
longer than the 12 year old uh so that's
what I would do I mean
you could put it in a money market
account and it just sit there and
they're gonna get like
20
22 000 maybe like a little bit of growth
in a money market account over that
length of time but oh yeah
um definitely but I like the idea of
investing it because I think that
there's there's some they they'll be
able to get more than twenty thousand uh
which is even uh more building on his
Legacy release how I see it yep I love
it good advice all right a couple of if
you had a guess what would you say are
going to be some of the highest paying
Industries or career Fields over the
next decade what would you do would you
take a guess I'll take a guess all right
um it's technology to Broad
no okay because there's a lot it makes
sense because I know what you're saying
developers yeah all of it okay I'm gonna
say that I'm gonna say medical field all
right here we go let's see if Rachel is
right she knows her stuff folks smart
asset analyze data across nearly 800
occupations as they look towards the
future to where we're going to see the
greatest job growth and income growth as
well
um now business and financial
occupations they outrank the physical
and social science jobs but there are
five specifically that are expected to
grow by more than 30 percent over the
next 10 years so these were the top five
here we go we don't have a drum roll uh
Rachel but uh they were uh nurse
practitioners in the medical field
45.7 percent growth wow so this is
you're not a doctor but you are a nurse
practitioner can do a lot of things that
doctors have traditionally done very
very attractive path uh and it's going
to grow substantially uh this is
interesting uh athletes uh professional
sports
35.7 percent uh information security
analyst there you go that falls under
your technology it absolutely is 34.7
growth statisticians this is All About
Numbers number crunching uh you see this
by the way uh growing in professional
sports as well where you've got a bunch
of bean counters and people that are
great with Statistics and analytics and
being used by professional uh supports
organizations then web developers you
specifically mentioned developers so
those are five that are going to grow
certainly in healthcare and Technical
occupations computer and mathematical
occupations as well
um
computer and information research
operations analysts are some more you're
going to see let's see personal
financial advisors management analysts
market research analysts you see a
pattern here so these are the jobs that
again are going to continue to grow as
technology evolves
and it further brings in a we've got to
use technology on some platform or some
level and then we use technology as it
relates to analysts and all this kind of
stuff it's coming down the numbers
numbers all the time so all that to say
we just love to talk work from time to
time and money
and uh interestingly enough when you
when you read an article like that and
we give you that information it would do
us all well to go okay what does the
path look like to get there
you know do I want to go into medicine
what does it look like to become a
doctor versus a nurse practitioner and
the money that you're going to be
spending the ROI yeah wait a second I'm
still taking care of patients yeah I'm
still providing Medical Care and so uh
very interesting to see how the job
economy has changed so much and such a
conversation for you parents to be
having even with your teenagers right
like the whole College discussion is
always a very fiery one but when you're
able to say okay you know your degree
what are you getting your degree in
what's what's the ROI my investment that
I'm putting out there and myself uh and
so again not not to say to go do
something that you hate and not
encouraging you to like say that to your
kids you know just to go into these
positions because they're they're paying
more but also to look to see okay what's
the thing that you love to do and how
can you make it work out in the real
world yeah no it's really good so
um that is a little bit of the landscape
as we see it now let's go to Rudy in
Miami Florida Rudy how can we help
hey how are you it's an honor today
thank you for the time you bet thanks
for calling what's up nope no problem
okay so to get to the meat and potatoes
of it so long story short
um I started a business with my ex 12
years ago
um very unique business
um where we manufactured bicycles
um it was great for many many years but
obviously like a typical storage year
um we broke up a few years back
um so you know for a few years you've
been trying to run the business kind of
like you know Co you know you know
however you want to call it but um but
in the last couple years it's kind of
been like uh a head button very very you
know dramatic type of uh you know
situation you know to the point where
you know it influences employees and
just just a very toxic environment
um and I've been you know kind of lay
down all the Frameworks of potentially
you know buy her out and see what we can
do but you know currently you know I'm
in a situation where I don't have the
funding that I can buy her out on and
she's actually the strong your partner
of us too so she actually uh you know
she she took a little of the bearing of
the of the credit you know just a little
more debt than I did so she's a little
more reluctant to walk away and really
leave anything on the table
um you know Loose Ends so you guys 50
50. yes we're 50 50. and that's and
that's not just a handshake that's
that's written down and we've got some
bylaws and we've got all that written
out
oh yeah all written out okay
um you know as interested as you can get
she's actually very very you know I
guess you could say old-fashioned fast
so like everything is overly tapered so
what's the what's the heart of your
question
now part of my question is so I want to
continue the business I actually started
the we started together technically 12
years ago but she didn't really start
coming in full time for like a year and
a half later so it really is my baby at
heart but I'm trying to figure out like
how do I get like I'm at the point where
I'm I've invested hundreds of thousand
dollars into this I'm at the point for
my own health sanity you know I studied
Finance in schools a random thing I got
into that it's almost worth just signing
over the paperwork and saying have it
all like it's not worth my health and
everything because that's your
relationship you know my new
relationship is amazing but it's
starting to affect it a little bit I you
know and it's just like
I don't know I feel like the energy if I
sign it off yeah and she doesn't want to
sell the business right like you guys
don't want to just get out both of you
she always says she does but she's kind
of like she comes from a lot of money
will she buy you will she buy you out
that's what I've been trying to do and
that's what I've been trying to get her
to do but she just keeps throwing it at
me like this is you know I'm I'm not
have no interest in this so I'm not
going to go any further yep so you can't
control her Rudy so for you and your
sanity I mean you could chalk it up to
what we call stupid text around here I'd
walk I think you answered the question
yourself you just kind of laid it out
hurt it's gonna hurt but it may be worse
in the long run Rudy I'm sorry yeah I
would follow your heart on this this is
why y'all don't go into business when
you're not married
man oh boy fruity sorry yeah you gotta
walk man this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
talking about your life your money your
work your relationships this is the
Ramsay show I'm Ken Coleman joined by
Rachel Cruz and Rachel of I I spy out of
my peripheral
uh some fancy boxes which leads me to
believe oh we have some Rachel Cruz
wallets now we've got a blue box a black
box and a taupe can I call it that
champagne oh champagne thank you very
much what does that mean oh I love the
wall so we have the Rachel Cruise wallet
that has the envelope sewn in and it is
the big wallet that you can use that if
you're especially if you're first time
budgeting and you are I'm gonna take
doing the envelope system that's a great
option but today do we have a special
deal but no this is a new wallet this is
the one I'm holding in my hands product
it's called The Rachel crew slim wallet
so it's a slim wall if you've been
budgeting for a while and you don't need
to cash out every category and do the
envelope system to the T and you want
you know you're running into Target for
a quick trip or you're running into
Starbucks and you just want to carry
something light uh this is why I created
the slim wallets you know what this is
this is the money clip for women I like
a very thin wallet yes and this is
fantastic look at this so there are card
holders to place your debit cards your
license and this is what there's one and
then there's one envelope
that zips that's all you need to decide
this one even has fake cash oh there you
go yeah yeah where's the camera at guys
zoom in on this I wanna can I talk about
this turn around so this is a card
holder hey just let me brag about you
guys here where's the camera camera guys
zoom in on this this is a key feature
for our video watch come on guys Zoom
faster there we go here we go look at
this see this she's talking about the
cards the debit card and then your see
I'd have a Costco card right here so you
got your ID maybe your Costco card
insurance card hey look but this is the
best feature look at that you snap right
oh did you hear that and it holds the
cards this is fantastic right and then
it zips it's open great and it holds
cash so if you want one envelope in
there and then a little side oh he's got
another pocket that you can put some
chains you can put some change in the
zipper that's right that's right and all
right yeah so it's uh as we did it with
our partnership with our friends at join
and they are a fair trade company so
they help employ people within India
that have been out of like really really
rough situations so they learn trade and
learn craft and they they're able to
help create these wallets which is
amazing so fantastic it's real leather
black we've got your traditional I call
that Camel yes and then you're calling
that champagne a metallic gold so you
get all these at ramsaysolutions.com
they are 39
uh great quality and again it's good
card holders you still get your envelope
one of them if you need it for that one
Christmas is around the corner might I
suggest it is true so I'm so excited
that Richard Cruise slim wallets you
should check them out you guys it's the
one I personally use I need a kiss is
great but I switch purses and it's like
between bags who do I gotta talk to
around here to get a Ken Coleman money
clip oh my gosh I gotta talk to your
people after the show I gotta talk to
people Preston Jeff all right that is
fantastic so there it is 39 39 Ramsay
solution
because it's nice quality because oh it
smells fantastic when you go and buy
something you know fake which is fine
but you know eventually like it's only
gonna last this stuff it wears and it is
so it's so Good by the way you know how
much I care about nice leather goods uh
if that gets scuffed up don't forget
shoe polish will take care of that oh
you can actually polish that wallet just
like you would a pair of dress shoes so
no matter how much it gets beat up the
point is it's going to look fantastic
thank you Ken I see nobody talks about
that part no no nobody cares I was not
in talking point because I'm the only my
friends you my friends brand new
information leather lasts forever that's
all I'm saying you should take care of
it all right Johnson City Tennessee is
where Jessica joins us Jessica how can
we help
hey so I have a question during this
housing boom my husband and I sold our
house we had two we sold one of them and
we took the 80 000 that we made and put
it on a piece of land
um to eventually build and now we're
living in a rental but renting out our
other home that does not have a mortgage
on it for pretty much the same price as
our rent so it's a wash the other house
is just too small for our family so
we're in about ninety five thousand
dollars of just regular debt I shouldn't
use that word but debt and then about
170 ish on the land I'm a nurse
practitioner my husband is retired
military and we make about after taxes
about 170 000 a year so my husband who
is older than me wants to go ahead and
start building our house
um but we really can't afford to do that
until we pay off all of our debt and pay
off the land so my husband's solution is
to sell our rental home that would
probably we take home about 200 about
about 200 000
um and then we wouldn't have a home but
we could start building maybe in the
next year and a half I like having a
rental home we always have
um since we've been married and I'm
struggling with thinking of not only
owning a home at all
so I guess it's down to me and my
husband you know differing on this and I
need some insight
yeah it's a great question
um
Jessica if I were to wake up in your
shoes tomorrow
um I'd sell the house
I'd sell it yeah and I would say take
that 200 pay off your Consumer Debt get
a you know a good chunk of the land debt
out of here you'll take out a
construction loan to build the house and
you guys rent somewhere yeah and put
money
um in your line item in your budget for
rent because you'll be paying Network
versus you know the renters we're paying
your rent now I understand what you're
saying there so you're going to be doing
out of pocket but for a short period of
time and you guys are able to clean up
this mess now the one thing Jessica I'm
gonna say though is by doing this this
ninety five thousand dollars of yeah
regular debt Consumer Debt so I'm
assuming it's car loans and credit cards
and personal loans and student loans
whatever you know it's probably a bunch
of that stuff it is when you do a a fail
swoop of paying off Consumer Debt with
something like a um selling something
like a home
my only fear Jessica is that the
behavior has not changed so if you guys
do this you have to promise each other
we're not getting back in this because
there's a benefit of people that say hey
we're gonna just knock out this 95 000
and pay off that 95 000 because we don't
have a rental home to sell we have to go
and sacrifice and people that go through
that process of sacrificing to get out
of debt they're not getting back in
because they knew what it took and so
yes is it painful to sell a house that
you got a rental house that you guys
have yeah it is but also you're you're
eliminating the debt so quickly so do
you hear what I'm saying though I don't
want you I don't want this Behavior the
bad habits that you guys had that
accumulated this 95 000 I don't want
those to say the same I want those to
change when you sell this rental house
that you guys agree together we're not
doing this again
okay that is great advice
awesome okay so that's what I would do
Jessica yeah I would sell it and then
you guys build your home and then the
thing is to just like you guys make
great money and so you're going to be
able to save up and get her if if you
want to you know be uh landlords again
and have a rental property you still can
later down the road in maybe a few years
I agree completely but you guys can
still do that that's still an option in
your future and Jessica I agree with
Rachel 100 and I would I would just give
one little perspective instead of
focusing on having to give up the rental
focus on how grateful you are for the
rental into what it's going to do for
you it is propelling you significantly
forward to living the life that you've
dreamed of and Rachel's exactly right we
can always get another rental but this
is a this is a gift I'd be grateful for
it I wouldn't be sad I'd be excited
about it and uh you know
giving up to go up is a phrase that John
Maxwell I used to work for John for many
years he used to say that all the time
sometimes you got to give up to go up
and I think that's in multiple areas of
our life and when I hear this story I
mean I get it she's like I love this
ring you know all the things
but
many times in life we do have to give up
not all the time but many times we do
have to give up to go upright if you're
going to lose weight you know and so the
goal is to lose weight you're gonna have
to give up all those wonderful little
treats that you love you know
relationally hey if we're gonna if we're
gonna power through and get our
relationship where we feel like we're
ready to get married or we're going to
build on our marriage and there's things
I'm gonna have to give up in certain
seasons for the relationship so that's
the idea here and I think if in those
moments when you have to give something
up Rachel if you can focus on the
gratitude for whatever you're giving up
and in that sacrifice it is propelling
you forward I think it makes it a lot
easier it's good great advice thanks
Jessica for the call yeah by the way
we've had several relationship-ish
questions so here's the deal if you're
in a dating relationship and money is
just weird or it's tension filled or
it's straight up controversial and ugly
Rachel and I want to take those calls
we're going to walk you through the
dating relationship and the money stuff
could be fun give us a call don't move
more Ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Rachel Cruz thrilled
you are with us the phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Levi joins us
next in Reno Nevada Levi how can we help
how are you all doing today well we're
having a blast Levi what's up
um well I want to say thank you first
off um started listening to you guys
that sick
that six really made it
awesome I can't actually just started
binging yours looking to change career
soon great
I've never been married
I'm proposed to
where does that fall on the baby steps
as far as buying a ring and how much
should someone spend
um I just uh finished paying off all my
debt last week so wow congratulations
congratulations how much did you pay off
oh it's about I'd say about 20 000 in
six months nice nice Levi
what would uh what's your emergency fund
gonna be three or six months four months
five months and how much will that be
right now it could be very little I'm in
a unique situation where I don't have
rent
um which is how I paid everything off so
quick awesome but um which rent this
area 20 000 would be a good one okay
all right how much are you thinking on
the ring we have Rachel here which I
feel like is an expert on this when it
comes to jewelry she's the expert in the
room no I think our rule of thumb is one
month's salary
oh is what you can use is what we would
recommend oh
and where does that fall as far as
should I be focusing on getting that
emergency fund before spending you know
three thousand dollars
um
it'd be nice to have some but also I'm
like I
we don't tell people to like stop the
baby steps to get married and to do all
this so if you can do both at the same
time uh save some money for the
emergency fund and then be saving on the
side too for the ring how long have you
been dating would be ideal
I've been with her for two and a half
years and we actually lived together in
her elderly parents uh who did not know
anything about Ramsey live with us
oh boy that was a loaded chocolate
that was a loaded chuckle what does that
mean
uh one of them actually needs to be in a
nursing home all right now we can't
afford it so well so in all seriousness
now I'm assuming that that she's going
to say yes right you feel pretty
confident we're going to get a yes out
of this okay is there expectations for
the parents to give you all to continue
to live together and for you all to have
to take care of them that's pretty heavy
burden
yes they uh it's a package deal uh she's
from Guam it's just kind of their
culture got it
and you're and you're all in on this
yes okay all right
that's great
um yeah so Levi to answer your question
I would just I would do both but
um well now that I know what I know
Rachel I'm gonna tell him to wait get
the emergency fund fully funded they're
living together
I mean what are we gonna wait a couple
more months I'd wait and get the
emergency fund well Mike you're
basically mayor you're playing married
so why aren't you married as soon as
possible oh I see what you're doing
there yeah I'd go quicker I would say
all right save it up go I mean you gotta
make a slush Loan in the budget yep yep
and just put some money aside yes well
you guys want a wedding or are you guys
kind of low-key with it and no big deal
I'm definitely low-keying yeah she will
want some kind of ceremony okay I've
never been married she has been okay
so the ceremony is important but yes
very inexpensive yep that's great so be
cash flowing that as well
um and then once you guys get married
combining your incomes and all of this
and if you have anything left to build
up the emergency funds uh do that but I
would I would
um yeah I'd get married as soon as I
would I would get married
yeah you guys know do you know where
you're going to get registered
he has no idea what I just said do you
even know what that means
I don't oh that's so great I knew it
well uh she can explain it to you
I swear Mary that's where engaged
couples they they go and they put their
gifts together old man
I just think that's right
I think it's funny because Levi is so
naive and I think that that's really
great he doesn't understand about all
the stuff he's about ready to get into
it they're older we got married young so
the registering was really exciting the
younger you are I feel like the more
exciting that stuff is I just thought it
was funny I didn't I did brought no
redeeming value at all I agree let's go
to David in Fredericksburg Virginia
David how can we help
uh yeah I wanted your take on a reverse
mortgage I'll be turning 65 next year
and
um getting tired of construction work
wondering if I could uh go part-time and
use a reverse mortgage so that I can
stay at the house that we had built for
a few years longer no David
um no we do not recommend reverse
reverse mortgages because it does
exactly what it says it to put you back
in Reverse you guys are progressing
paying off your house and building this
equity and you're going to start right
back over and so it's it is a product
that is marketed to 60 plus you know
whenever you look at any even even I
mean seriously no it's true seriously
David it really is I'm calling because
it is it's doing exactly what you are
thinking it's like oh that's kind of
nice I can pull back from work all of
that and that that it's not it's not the
way to go because you're gonna be losing
equity in it and and it's it's not smart
not smart at all so what David you said
you're 60
four I'll be 65 in January okay okay and
uh how much you guys have left on the
mortgage
uh we've got left on at about 180 and
it's valued at almost 500. oh nice do
you guys have any other debt oh yeah
yeah we've we've had the land forever uh
we got about 20 000 in debt okay keep um
paying off and going on vacation and
running back up and then paying it off
okay David okay how much listening to
you guys has been a good sin good how
much do you guys make a year
uh we make about 65 000 a year 65 okay
um is it all credit card debt
uh yes
uh well
uh yeah yes it is credit card debt
because here's the thing too David and
it might be that might be high on the
credit card debt it's probably more like
about ten thousand
okay so what's the other debt of the 20
what else do you owe
uh maybe some Medical in the wife we've
we've been budgeting quite well and um
so it's it's something that we've
learned over the years to uh try and
keep a control on that spending Beast
okay and David do you guys have anything
in retirement
uh about 30 40 000 okay
um okay I've got some properties that
I'll be selling um okay I've got it for
years
and it means uh I'll start selling some
of my heavy equipment that I've got that
haven't been using okay so if you lay so
if you sell the land liquidate property
or liquidate the the machines everything
how much do you think you'll you'll come
out
uh probably close to three hundred
thousand no okay nice
um because I'm just thinking of your
retirement and you guys long term
because I know you probably want to pull
back from working for sure
um but these the the habits that you
guys have been in David like you said
you're like well we go on vacation we
pay some stuff off we go back all this
this reverse mortgage it's gonna just
magnify the bad habits that you guys
have created so it's not going to be
good for you in any sense it's not a
great it's it's a terrible
um situation in general
but also when you when you guys are not
you're not being disciplined in it and
so I would if I were you and your wife I
would sit down and really map out a plan
and say okay we are 65 years old we owe
180 still in the mortgage you got 30 000
in retirement twenty thousand dollars in
debt uh and it's time to really start
cleaning this up David I mean honestly
be paying off this debt as quickly as
possible you guys need some Savings in
the bank for an emergency fund and then
we're gonna start piling on retirement
and whether that means selling the lands
early to to get some money in but I I
want to be able to map out I want you to
be able to map out a plan to get you to
retirement and reversing the mortgage
doesn't do that it gets you back into a
horrible situation you're not
progressing forward when you do that
yeah great advice there and hey you
still got time and you got some assets
that you're going to be able to get a
windfall of cash so really dive into the
baby steps and really Walk It Out Hold
on the line also I'll pick up and give
you guys a free trial to Financial Peace
University I want you and your wife to
go through it that'll do it for this
hour of the Ramsay show thank you so
much for being with us
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramseysolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show so we talk about your life
specifically your money your
relationships your work we want to give
you a clear path
that has hope and practical steps if you
can turn your life around in any of
those areas it is a free phone call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five I'm Ken Coleman and
Rachel Cruz joins me this hour we are
here for you let's go to Detroit
Michigan Nicole is there Nicole how can
we help
hi thank you for speaking with me today
so um we have a 16 year old daughter and
she got her life in August this year and
we did the um Dave recommendation we got
her an inexpensive car and she paid for
half and and that's all good so my
question now is um Michigan is sort of
notoriously high for car insurance so
we've got that and then obviously
repairs and gas and things like that so
what is your program's recommendation
for how to sort of what to have her pay
for what we would pick up things like
that as far as expenses
um I don't think we really have a
a
hard and fast rule Nicole with it I
think it's going to depend maybe kid by
Kid by your you and your husband's
financial situation
um I think a lot of that kind of comes
into play and the the whole idea of
matching the car yeah it's just a great
idea for the kids to have skin in the
game saving up having a big purchase uh
that they're a part of and that they
probably end up taking care of that car
better than if it was just handed to
them uh so all of that goes into play
but when it comes to actually
maintaining it the car insurance
um I I honestly see I can I you have
teenagers I'll be curious what you what
you think but I think either path
is okay so there's some parents they're
like nope it's up to you you got to get
a part-time job you gotta handle these
expenses
um it's gonna be your responsibility and
I think there's I think there's good in
that but I also don't think you're
harming your kid if you don't do that so
for instance Nicole I'll say growing up
my parents we had to pay for half of our
car and they took care of all of what
you said they took care of the car
insurance and the maintenance and they
opened up a checking account for us and
they gave us an amount of money it was
not a lot he they claim it's the amount
of money that it takes to like for you
to be to for you to live as a teenager
month to month on all of your extra
stuff right whether it's hanging out
with friends or gas for your car all
that and they put that dollar amount
which I think they cut the number in
half honestly because it was not a lot
in a checking account and we got bitter
at all no I still remember it so because
we all had to get jobs that we couldn't
live off of that that amount of money
they gave us everyone like you had to go
babysit you had to work which I think
was part of the motivation yeah uh so we
had we were in charge of gas when we
went out with friends uh school clothes
like they had an expectation for us if
here are the things that you have to pay
for out of this account that will help
fund and some of it but you're
responsible of managing that account
you're not necessarily responsible for
all the expenses and the financial side
but you are responsible for managing it
and like I said it wasn't a lot of money
so if we wanted to hang out more with
friends or go to more movies whatever we
had to go work and make that money
um so there was still a level of
responsibility and learning about money
as a 16 17 18 year old but we weren't uh
responsible for having to pay for all
the insurance and all the maintenance
and so I would say and that ends which
is the other side of the equation I
don't think we were damaged by maybe
some maybe the American public would
think otherwise no I don't think you're
damaged I just think you're holding on
to some bitter feelings you should
probably talk with Dave about no I
remember it was like 150 bucks a month
and I was like well back then that was a
lot of money for a kid I don't think you
appreciate how much money that is back
no After I filled up my car I remember I
remember all of it and I were thinking
it was like the 17th of every month and
I'm like I have no money I have to I
have to go babysit this weekend to earn
any kind of money so
uh so here's what we're gonna do I would
agree with you uh Nicole we're gonna pay
car insurance and maintenance but I've
told our kids you're paying your gas
because right so they're in charge of
their gas they're in charge of gas and
the reason is is because there's an
expensive inflationary times Ken Coleman
get a job you know or get your friend to
pick you up she does have a part-time
job at a dog kennel she doesn't work no
no no no yeah I'm just talking about my
I'm just saying I I would cover
insurance and maintenance but I am going
to make my kids cover their gas because
number one they need to learn the cost
of things like that and and then you
know you get to school you get to work
anything outside of it you know you're
paying gas period
I mean you can't you don't have any gas
you gotta go to work and if you got to
go somewhere in the meantime you got a
friend to come pick you up that's where
I'm gonna draw a hard line good for you
pay for gas for crying out loud okay if
your kids if they want to go out to kids
go to the movies these days that was
always like the thing we did yeah they
do okay so they want to go see a movie
what do they say my kids yeah they come
to you they go hey uh I've been invited
or want to go with a couple of my
buddies to see it and that begins the
conversation at which point you know
it's like so where how do they get how
do they pay for the movie uh out of
their out of their account they have to
okay okay we all funds those accounts at
all or it's strictly only the jobs that
they have we're still doing the chores
you do some basic things around the
house we'll put a little money in there
and there's the occasional like you know
if they're in during a season of school
or Sports so both my boys play football
so they can't do school and work and
play football right now you know they
really can't and so it's limited so
I mean I guess it could work on a
Saturday but they're working out and
everything so you know we'll we'll fund
some of those things but that is based
on again the chores around the house
sure and the room's got to be clean you
know yeah and I think too we can get we
can get like very uh weekends because
you and I are really healthy individuals
can get very legalistic about every the
little things right whether it's like
they're gonna pay for cut this this is
the the overarching idea though is Meg
maker always says it I think it's a
great quote you're not just trying to
raise good kids you're trying to raise
kids to become good adults right so what
am I teaching my 16 year old what does
she or he need to know to be a
successful adult later in life so what
are and I think you can go about that
all different ways I think there's I
think there's a lot of different
um directions and angles pay for gas
don't pay for gas give them some money
and let them work don't give them any
money make them all work like I mean
it's all of it but you're just trying to
raise an adults so it's like here let me
let me that's the heart and the spirit
behind it Nicole but you know I'd say
this if if one of my kids was rocking it
you know and they had a great business
and they started with teens and they had
it going and I saw how much money
they're making and going okay well we're
gonna Slide the insurance over your way
now
I really would I think it comes down to
how much they're making and then they've
got the responsibility but I mean I
think that I really would I think I
would go all right you're killing it
you're crushing it you're able to start
a business if I was a Coleman child then
I would be like no they would be killing
it
punishing the ones that are being
successful and then the one that's not
being said the one that's not doing a
business you're gonna just pay their
insurance well it's fair point
okay there we go Hey look it's real time
you got me on that one I'm just saying
like the more successful they are and
that they're crushing it they need more
responsibility yeah like I'm not going
to continue to magnify that's what I was
getting but you got me you back me into
a corner I don't know what's happening I
won the segment Rachel one can zero
that's right by the way we are uh
looking forward to some calls if you're
in a dating relationship okay and you're
having some tension around the money we
are gonna help you
so we'll take those calls on top of
everything else she is Rachel Cruz I'm
kid Coleman and this is the ram
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
joined by Rachel Cruz and we are here
for you taking your calls on money life
work relationships uh and we're uh
really really hoping that we get a few
more relationships we've had so many
relationship calls on the show today yes
and so we said all right if you're in a
dating relationship Rachel and I want to
take on a little the dating Dynamics and
money because if you don't get that
figured out in dating and then you try
to figure out their marriage it could be
messy so we'll take some of those calls
along with other things we'll see what
happens but first we go to uh Fort Myers
Florida oh my goodness uh that's where
hurricane Ian just did so much
distraction Erica is on the line Erica
how can we help
hi nice to talk to you both today
absolutely are you right there in ground
zero
um we live pretty far inland
um from the beaches but so our home was
spared um thank goodness oh good well we
have lots of friends that did not
um make it the same so lots of homes
that are destroyed lots of cars um so
we're just trying to pick up all the
pieces and just be there for everybody
that we can oh man my goodness I'm so
glad you guys are okay how can we help
you thank you
um so just a question regarding um
building a new home in this current
economy
um over the summer we sold our home we
did very well on it because we bought
very low and kind of sold right at the
time before things started to slow down
a little bit so we made almost four
hundred thousand dollars that we were
able to pocket
so um with that we planned to build our
Dream Home my husband is an architect
and this has kind of always been our
Dream to move forward and do this so we
were for a rental we were totally
planning to move forward with that and
then the interest rate started to go up
and it just seems like the economy is
just not
um really working with us very well
right now so we're just kind of scared
we are we are debt free
um like I said we're in a rental we have
about 300 000 cash right now going into
this project but we're both just kind of
nervous and um not sure if we should do
it right now but then also knowing if we
wait things could just get worse
um so just kind of looking for your
opinion on that just some wisdom yeah
absolutely
um well you guys are in a unique
um situation even with the hurricane so
tell me this because I'm not I'm not
sure
um
the answer to this question but will
Builders is there going to be I would
assume a big influx of building because
of the destruction that just happens
which is that correct
yeah I mean it's definitely going to get
busy it's been really busy around here
um you know for the past several years
and then with covid you know supplies
are definitely on back order so we had
totally anticipated this taking longer
than normal yeah
um but we're prepared for that but the
current destruction though like just
again within this the last few days uh
does that play a big factor in the
economy there in Florida
um we aren't exactly sure I mean
definitely our um our beaches and our
area bring a lot of money in during
Seasons so I'm not sure how that's going
to look what's the price point well I'm
saying for Builders though like I'm just
thinking if you're gonna go good if guys
are going to build is there like a big
influx of Builder I I I'm saying all
that to say because it's all around
supply and demand I agree and the demand
is high which it has been over the past
few years
um you know Nationwide uh the demand has
been high to build uh but supply has
been down that's obviously what caused
the prices to go up and what we're
seeing now is the demand has lowered and
the supply is actually kind of catching
up so my answer to you uh in general
would be I would feel good around spring
to go ahead and start and start building
around spring because you we keep seeing
the with the supply and the numbers with
Lumber and everything it's getting
better and better and better that's
right uh offer is actually back down
yeah so you're gonna be in a good
position I just didn't know how much of
a hurricane that destroys a whole city
how much that will will I don't think
anybody knows right now Erica how much
yeah what were you guys targeting as as
to the price of this house that you
would build
um our current budget on it is about 850
000
um we think that we can do it for at
that or less okay and you got are you
planning to put 300K down
we we are planning to put down more than
that
um since we are renting and we're debt
free we're able to save
um a ton of money right you have about
400 000 from your home correct that you
sold right yeah yeah but we paid off
some debt we paid off the land that we
own okay with that yeah so you got 300K
yeah and then you're going to put more
so here's I just want to take on what
you asked which was uh the interest
rates economies I'll play with this I
wouldn't wait very long because I don't
know that the interest rate situation is
going to fluctuate a whole bunch I mean
we're hearing uh in the news the last
couple days that the FED is expected now
and again nobody knows this but the
people that watch this are expecting the
FED to race rates by another half point
now that's not directly tied to mortgage
rates but you don't know what mortgage
rates are going to do and so sitting
around sitting around it's not like the
stock market watching it like that I
think we're out of a period of those
crazy low interest rates I I don't know
how long it will be if we or if ever
we'll see stuff in the twos or threes
again so my point is and you're such a
strong cash position and you have no
debt I'm not disagree with Rachel in
Spring but I'm going if you guys have
that big of a down payment and you guys
are disciplined financially I wouldn't
just sit around and watch the mortgage
rates we just don't know what's going to
happen anybody tells you any different
is crazy
right so I would move forward what we've
talked about right yeah but it's it's
just you know there's so many different
factors being that my husband designs
homes for a living you know if if
nobody's Building Homes anymore because
interest rates have gone up you know
what I mean so it's just we're kind of
in that unique position of who knows
what the next two years is going to hold
yeah and that's going to be his income
be the same oh I hear you yeah yeah well
his income be affected because of it
yeah right
um yeah well yeah I mean the ccs are
though I I still would I would move
forward maybe give it a few months uh
just to save up some more money and let
the supply catch up even more over in
the next few months and let the demand
keep going down because you're just
going to get better prices so what's
going to end up happening right yeah and
do you see any evidence that that his
job is in Jeopardy as you see any signs
or is this just you kind of worrying
looking at the headlines
um no not currently he he does very well
for himself he just started his own
company almost two years ago
um so he does very well his income
varies but is somewhere around 250 to
300 000. that's awesome so we're in a
really great position
um we just want to be as smart as we
possibly can be because this has been
our dream and we don't want to make a
bad decision and then have to sell yeah
no I don't you know you are too smart to
do that to make a bad decision I think
Rachel's advice is great yeah Erica if
you called us and you're like we got
four thousand dollars and
three hundred thousand and student loans
and all this right like we get some of
those calls I'm like you don't need to
buy a house right now but Erica you guys
are in the part you're it I mean you've
literally done exactly what we teach and
at that point that's that's a little bit
of the rule of thumb if you don't look
at what the Market's doing look what
you're doing and are you guys in a
position to do it so if you wait a
little bit longer again a few months I
think we're going to continue to see
Supply go back up demand's going to kind
of continue to go back down it's been
really it's been a soft real estate
market here for the last little bit uh
and I don't think it's gonna pop back up
anytime soon so uh yeah I would wait a
few more months and then I would I would
do it I'd move forward
thanks for the call I do think you're
going to see a lot of people well we'll
see but are people going to slow down
buying homes as we come into the midterm
elections to see what's going on you
know are they watching what the fed's
gonna do
um it should be very interesting but to
you know there are still a lot of homes
available in the United States so if you
just look at how many homes are still
available what a healthy Supply is uh
there are a lot but but it's not as many
as you would they want to see in a
healthy Supply so still there's some
markets that are softening and prices
but overall you know it's not the big
bubble that everybody said might happen
and that's a good sign so it'd be very
interesting to see but you're right
Builders aren't building at the rate
that they need to be that we would like
to see so more Builders building but my
heart's uh just heavy thinking about the
pictures that we've seen the last week
in Fort Myers beautiful Coastal area and
just flattened
um and so glad that um that she and her
family are okay my goodness
well good hour uh it's not a done hour
it's a good half hour actually see I
just lost
we still have two more places to go
folks which means you could still get in
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by Rachel Cruz triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Logan in Oklahoma City
Oklahoma Logan how can we help
hi um so my girlfriend and I are thank
you for taking my call sure
um my girlfriend and I are both in
school and currently we are saving up to
buy a house
um we also at the same time are both
wanting to start our own small
businesses and at the same time we're
trying to get married or we want to get
married and we want to do all these
different things and my question is is
what should I prioritize on doing first
or should I multitask no you're trying
to do too much
and I love it you guys got Big Dreams
but um you know uh there are seasons and
and you got too much going on Rachel I
feel like first thing we ought to be
focused on is getting married yeah how
old are you guys Logan
uh we are both or she's 21 and I'm 20.
okay awesome
um how long have you guys been together
we've been together for three years okay
and so you're it I mean for each other
when were you thinking you were going to
get married before you call with all
three of these these these plates
spinning
um honestly out of all the three plates
I am Mo I think it's the easiest one to
do is to get married so that is on the
back burner in my opinion oh or my
schedule
why
well
um I feel like getting married well so
what's easier getting married or getting
a house well getting a house you have to
have money getting married all you do is
go down to the courthouse finishing
school it's a lot more difficult than I
think saving up money for a house in my
opinion
um I I just think that it's a lot easier
to
to uh get married
that's a very interesting logic I I
would put it first on the list I mean
you know that she's the one you were
certain about that are you guys in
school
yes how much longer do you guys have
till you graduate
she has about
I think till December so just a couple
months and I have about two years left
okay
uh what's she gonna be doing after
school
job-wise well our goal our goal is to
her to start her own business that's an
at home daycare
and at home daycare okay yeah that's
what we really wanted that's what she
really wants okay
um
and is that is that feasible to cash for
just her because you guys aren't married
so for her that December is coming I
mean that's in 90 days so
in January does she have the money for
insurance does she have an LLC does she
does she has she been doing her work to
open up a business does she have the
money to do that because that's a very
expensive liability business that she's
about to walk into so is she prepared
for all of that
yeah um we have saved up a lot of money
Logan wait wait hold on you guys aren't
married so there's no we you have money
she has money so how much has she saved
up for her business
okay so she has around ten thousand
dollars saved up okay and I have around
fifteen thousand dollars saved up okay
so together I I know it's uh
presumptuous to talk before we are
married about having things together it
is I understand that yeah um but yeah
you keep doing it okay so so we're gonna
keep it separate just for the fun of the
conversation you know he called us yeah
we're just gonna we're gonna walk down
this path okay so you got so so she has
ten thousand dollars does she have any
debt
no we neither of us are dead Okay so she
does not have Carl on student loans
credit cards nothing
correct okay and how much will it take
for her to open up
a home daycare business in January
around three thousand dollars
hmm really seems a little low Logan for
me
for the insurance a lot of things okay
okay so okay so what do y'all have
well we have all the different furniture
that you need like the cots and the
chairs and she already has inventory
like uh different books
um and a lot of the costs for the album
daycare is like
um the the fixed cost so I guess the
variable cost you purchase on like a
monthly basis like food
um
and the the insurance is expensive
um
but
uh what do we call it does she get a
business license and has she opened up
an LLC is she you know or is she going
to be a freelancer she can do a 1099 is
she gonna do a W-2 like does she have
all of that worked out I have a question
okay I'm sorry no no no no no you're
great you're you're digging into no no
and it goes in here doesn't this imply
Logan that she has a house to be able to
do the said home-based daycare in and
you have no home yes so where's the home
at
currently
currently and this is this is the main
reason I called currently we live
um inside of a rental property that my
stepdad owns rent free
okay but where would the daycare be in
January as Rachel was walking through
this where would the daycare be
in your dad's rental
correct
where's Dad at in this whole equation
because he owns the home
um
well the original idea for us moving
into the rental so that I could help him
fix up the place and so that we could
save up money to uh buy our own home and
that is what we've been doing thus far
okay
um but since we're both almost done with
school we both really want to start
working towards starting our own
business right that's the that's the
best thing I've heard in this call is we
want to work towards it
um I'm gonna try to squish your dreams
Logan no okay because here here's the
reality let me just paint you let me
paint you a picture Logan let's just
pretend for a second if we're in
Rachel's world let's pretend I like this
she graduates in December she goes and
she's a full-time Nanny somewhere she
gets the experience of working with a
family or she works for a preschool
somewhere where she doesn't have
liability okay so she's she is not
attached to something long-term I'm
getting a fist pump from Ken Coleman
just so you know Logan so so she's doing
this she's making an income she's
working you're working your way through
school you guys can get get married okay
I I'm not a fan of living together
before marriage if you guys know that
this is it I'm not and I got married at
21. I was young so and it's it's been a
wonderful 13 years with Winston Cruz so
I I'm fine with people getting married
young some people have an issue with it
I don't uh if you guys know that you're
it so so I would have her graduate her
start working you guys together then get
married next spring because or whenever
right this right world so let's pretend
you get married in the spring plan a
wedding between now uh four or five
months you guys get married small
wedding it's wonderful you guys move out
of step dad's home to your own place and
you rent an apartment for a little bit
you guys get steady you finish school
you guys are saving she's working you're
working part-time you graduate in two
years and then when we see where we're
at because opening a business where you
you could it just adds a level of
factors Logan for you guys uh that I
just don't think is wise starting out I
don't think rushing into a home uh your
first year of marriage is wise I don't
think opening two businesses that you
guys kind of think you know but you
don't even have a place to do it is
really wise I would really work on
yourselves
no I sound like a therapist uh in your
marriage and and build a really solid
foundation relationally and financially
and then uh after you graduate you guys
get your money together put a great down
payment on a great starter home move
into your house uh and then look to see
from there okay what cash do we have to
start one of these businesses because I
know you have a business you want to
start she has one that she wants to
start and and let me tell you and in
three years Logan life is going to look
a whole lot different than it is right
now so a lot of work Rachel's World okay
I endorse Rachel's world I'm living in
Rachel's world I'm the mayor and I'm
like okay here's the deal Logan
um you guys have a great vision you've
got some mountain tops and I applaud you
for that you're young and that's a good
thing you cannot climb a mountain
overnight this is a journey and I just
want you to have some patience and it's
really hard to have patience so in no
way am I dampening where you're at but
my friend there is a season for
everything Rachel just laid out a
completely beautiful plan and if you
just are patient
you're going to be able to experience
and live all of those dreams out I
promise because you're not in la la land
the you're sharp young man you look up
at 26 and y'all will be freaking killing
it I mean seriously and that's still
young but yes have the patience build a
strong Foundation under you guys first
and foremost before you rush into
anything here's the other thing you
never know what's going to happen in the
next three weeks much less than the next
three years
um and so you guys are gonna get there
hang on
one step at a time and you're gonna get
there great stuff Rachel's world I gotta
get a t-shirt we should yeah this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
joined by Rachel Cruz
thrilled to have you with us today our
scripture of the day is Proverbs 12 17
an honest witness tells the truth but a
false witness tells lies our quote of
the day from Robin Williams but in
character apparently I saw that and I
thought is that real but it is did you
ever see Mrs Doubtfire I owned it in a
VHS table oh well that's very nice uh
this is uh Mrs Doubtfire as played by
the incomparable Robin Williams I admire
that Honesty Natalie that's a noble
quality never lose that because it often
disappears with age or entering politics
well said Mrs Doubtfire that's great I
tried to do I was trying to think it was
the little coup that he did as her voice
what was the name literally God that was
such a good movie it was a great movie
man I need to go back and re-watch that
one again fantastic character Sally
Fields man yeah yeah and who wouldn't do
that what Dad wouldn't do that to be
close to his kids so there you go
Natalie excuse me uh Natalie was in the
character Nick
technically wow words and and
everything's hard for me in this last
hour I don't know what's going on Nick
is on the line at Grand Rapids Michigan
Nick how can we help
hi um thank you for taking my call I'm
just calling I just got married three
days ago
congratulations please hold on a second
you're not calling us from the honeymoon
are you I know it actually I'm at work
and we didn't take a honeymoon all right
very good
um but anyway
um so we are looking to buy a home right
now we're both living at my parents and
we're looking to buy a home and I guess
we're kind of I'm more wondering why
um if we're gonna plan on selling it
like in five years why not just do a
third year right now instead of 15.
well why would you sell it in five
well I figure this this would just be a
starter home I'm actually a carpenter so
I'd like to build my next home
um in a few years obviously like I said
five to seven years something like that
um so I'd like to settle it like kind of
fix it up and then flip it almost okay
um well my my first piece of advice
thank you didn't ask for this but if I
were you guys I wouldn't just rush into
a home I mean you guys got married three
days ago
so part of me would say hey for the next
six seven eight months I would move out
of your parents and go rent somewhere
even if it's a six-month lease at an
apartment or something just to for you
guys to have your own space build your
own world uh something just happens when
and I understand people moving back home
to save money I mean people do it for
lots of reasons uh but there's just
something to be said about having the
Dignity of you know when you open the
refrigerator you guys got to decide
who's going to go to the store to get
food like you don't mean like there's
just these day-to-day decisions that I
think are
um really important for a newlywed
couple to walk through so that would be
my first piece of advice is go rent
somewhere and then do you guys have any
Consumer Debt
uh no we are completely not free awesome
you guys have some money saved uh yeah
we have combined 61 000 in the bank oh
amazing fantastic great job so we use
some of that I guess for your down
payment
yeah we were looking at we just were
doing the numbers yesterday I think
having 11 000 emergency fund 5 000 left
over for other stuff so I don't know
what that is like yeah 38 000 down
payment and then there's like closing
costs and stuff like that yeah for sure
okay that's awesome Nick well well done
on running your numbers
um yeah so with a 30-year mortgage like
I understand some people say well we're
gonna just pay it like a 15 or we're
gonna pay more on it uh or we're in this
time frame but and for me personally I
would still go ahead and do the 15-year
because you're going to be building
Equity within that uh be paying more on
the principal
um and you're gonna you're gonna have
more when you sell and you never know
what's going to happen you know you guys
may be in there longer than you than you
even expect so our rule of thumb always
is a 15-year fixed rate uh with your
payment being no more than 25 of your
take-home pay right and I guess
um the reason I'm asking this is I'd
like to do 15 but with our income we
have about a 20 down payment
um for houses that we're looking at and
with our income we uh aren't at that 25
percent with a 15-year
well okay so then what house would you
be able to get with it being in that 25
percent
well that's like if we did a 30-year our
payment would be like no I know I know
yeah yeah but I'm just saying then at
that point it ends up being just too
much house because if we always again we
do the math in that formula of the 15
years so so if you're calling us we're
going to always advise you that way uh
so that would mean that you would just
have to get get a different house
okay that makes sense yeah okay probably
not what you wanted to hear Nick but
that's what I would say and and again
houses like they're
um they're a big part of our world
uh it's where it's a very personal
purchase it's a personal part of our
Lives it's where you raise your kids
it's where you eat dinner it's where you
have your first marriage fight at the
kitchen table right like I mean like all
this stuff your house is is a very
um intimate part of your lives and so I
just don't want it to take over Nick and
that's why we always and we're I know I
understand it's a conservative formula
that we use but it's the one we're just
where your house doesn't have you and
ends up being a burden yeah and I think
because you're as a carpenter want to
build your own home one day I would rent
a little bit longer and and I would rent
that entire time I really would to be
safe oh and not even buy I would not buy
yeah I would wait save up you've proven
that you saved I think the goal here
initially was well let me go buy a house
flip it make some more money to fast
forward everything but again I just
think that that brings in all kinds of
risk you never know what's going to
happen and I I agree with you I I'd sit
tight actually I would rent and save
save save save and build the house that
you want to built now thank you for the
call Alex is up in San Bernardino
California Alex how can we help
hi hi hi
uh so my goal is to be a DJ I'm 20 years
old I live with my parents and I'm
currently going to college
and I just want to drop out
do you think I should man up and finish
college or do you think I should get a
job move out and run
okay what would you drop out to do
if you dropped out today what would be
the plan
I've worked at Amazon
for what purpose just to stop going to
class
yeah and just uh what are you pursuing
right now what path are you on in
college what major
uh marketing and you've no desire to do
that
not really I'm not really into college
well I get it for school so what's a
full-time what's a full-time DJ Gonna
Make I I don't know and so that's a
serious question what's that what's that
possibility look like
um that's true I turned 21 soon so I'm
gonna try to apply for clubs near my
area but so you don't know
I should look at that yeah okay so
here's the point I don't we don't drop
out of anything into nothing right so I
I totally get that you're not into
college believe me dude I don't have a
degree I couldn't stay in college either
I I get it but to drop out to nothing
just to go to Amazon without knowing
what the plan is let's say you do that
okay you drop out you go work at Amazon
that's honorable you're making money
whatever
okay but you have no idea what a path to
being a successful DJ looks like and
then you look into it and you go oh I I
it's not as uh lucrative or as exciting
as I thought it was once I actually dug
in so now what yeah what I'd rather you
do is sit tight have some discipline
okay and then what I would do is I'd
start hanging out with guys that are DJs
I would start you know uh if you got to
work you know behind the bar or
something like that you know uh just to
get around DJs you're not even 21 you
probably can't even do that the point is
you get in you get in close proximity to
DJs for real and really understand like
what do you make what do you make on a
weekend because there's a difference
between a DJ and a high-end Club in
South Beach
and the DJ in you know Sheboygan
Wisconsin I mean it's just different
like you want to DJ weddings I mean you
gotta know what you're dealing with so
it's true you gotta know I know Alex
listen if I were you I would I would
stick out College okay I know it's it's
it's a drag yeah just to stick it out no
but when you when you graduate and you
have a college degree you are there is a
marketable sense that he will have if he
wants to go into something else if he
wants to go into business one day or
something like all right it's fair I
think that that's a I think it's a I do
personally is figure out the future yeah
and and I wouldn't just I would not I
wouldn't drop out right now I want to
know what a path to being a DJ looks
like yeah and if it's not successful
what else is out there yeah but stay put
until you figure it out do you
understand what I'm saying yeah I
understand all right there you go thanks
for the call out I need to learn more
about you I was going to say your your
knowledge though is sweeping well I've
been to some nice clubs down in Miami
and uh that's a whole different ballgame
they're flying these guys and gals over
from Europe I know these things she is
Rachel Cruz I'm kid Cohen hey thanks to
everybody in the booth thank you America
for listening this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]